you're in this big-time movie the
Martian and it's directed by Ridley
Scott now Ridley Scott is iconic
legendary director and he's famous for
getting very few takes like the thing
I've always heard about Ridley Scott is
he get this is like four it was like
four takes a lot of directors are do
like 50 takes and so that's comfortable
for the actor because they get a lot of
chances at it with him it's like he does
two three maybe sometimes four it takes
and he's like I'm moving on yeah that's
gotta be intimidating well he sets up
like four cameras and that's it like he
has a bunch of cameras but you don't
really notice them and then you get like
kind of three four chances like he
doesn't say that but he's just like he's
always like great moving on like so you
kind of feel as an actor you kind of
bring it so like I had a scene where
like I like I fit in a wastebasket but
in like and then I do some work and then
I get up and it's the first take I was
like really nervous it was like my first
time and then like I got up and I spit
in the wastebasket I could do the thing
and I get up and I like just eat it like
I slipped so hard I was like wow and
everybody and then I just get up and I'm
fine and I keep going in the scene right
and then after the scenes done he comes
up he's like that was great that's in
the movie that's in the movie it's in
the mood when you see when you see me in
the movie and I eat it that's really
eating it yeah it's really true but he
said that he did that in a film and
Louise - right like apparently lose
anything yeah he was like oh that's
always the realest stuff and I'm just
like got eyes back I'm like yes he did
the same thing in Thelma and Louise yeah
if you watched them when Louisa is a
scene where he's like chasing after her
like I ever and his her husband in the
movie and he like Falls he was like that
was not planned but they just used right
so there's that motif in his movies of
banana peels every everywhere like
that's a good thing Pro mean it is ah so
many banana go off the cliff at the end
that was an accident
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography